well brian we can expect to see a
vaccination campaign by the southern
nevada health district
once the pfizer and modern vaccines are
approved here
eight news now reporter kristen drummond
shows us the effort and also who it
plans to target
preparing for a covid19 vaccine campaign
rollout
we're developing messages right now and
for various groups the southern nevada
health district finalizes facts to soon
share with the public
we'll have a faq pretty soon on our
website
and some information there on how to get
the vaccine
joanne rue piper is the director of
clinical services at the health district
she says the effort targets everyone
including minority communities
we have specific funding for hispanic
families and african-american families
because those
groups have been affected by kovid more
than others
how difficult do you think it may be to
try and convince
people to take the vaccine to me it's
very unknown at this point we need to
move forward
dr jeffrey ebersol studies immune system
responses
the immunologist at unlv understands
some
question the effectiveness the reality
is that both of these companies have
been working with these
this type of nucleic acid vaccine for
probably a decade
he says the vaccine includes a part of
the virus that triggers an immune
response
you get injected into your arm your
muscle cells pick up this
rna and then our own cells
actually make the antigen the potential
cure to bringing normalcy to the
community
with the help of health leaders we'll
use all of our
tools that we can to get people to take
a vaccine
kristen drummond 8 news now
and if you would like some more
specifics about the vaccine the cdc
website is really helpful in breaking
down all the details for you